hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to a DS
kitchen it's back-to-school time which
means we're all looking for ways to
successfully fill our lunch bags with
lots of healthy ingredients that our
kids are actually getting so today i've
partnered with the healthy greens
institute to bring you my three favorite
sandwiches that you and your kids are
gonna love to help you crush this brown
bag game the cue a great sandwich is of
course a great bread
sorry keto dieters but you can't have a
sandwich without the carbs and dieters
you should not fear the bread while BMI
isn't the best marker of health you
might be surprised to know that there
was a recent University of Saskatchewan
study that found no difference in the
BMI between grain eaters and abstainers
and that's really not a shock to me
since greens are a great source of fiber
to help keep you satiated and they also
contribute important B vitamins Foley
and iron I love me a good PB&J on
classic and rich white bread I also try
to get a nice variety of whole grains in
my day like whole grain rye and whole
grain wheat give me a good balance of
essential nutrients throughout the week
so if you're part of the 80% of Canadian
adults or 50% of kids and teens that the
study revealed are not getting enough
grains in your day you need these three
amazing Sammy's in your life let's do
this first up my chickpea avocado
sandwich on rye bread to a large bowl
add your avocado and give it a good mash
add some fresh lemon juice olive oil and
season it lightly with salt tipping your
chickpeas and stir it all together and
now it's time to build start with a
slice of marble rye bread scoop a
generous portion of the avocado and
chickpea filling top of grated carrot
grated beets and I'll thought the
sprouts and then sandwich it all
together with a second slice of marble
rye I'm using rye for the sandwich which
really research suggests may help
improve blood glucose levels and can you
say she added longer
next my grilled eggplant tahini and
hummus on whole grain bread I start with
a generous slice of whole grain bread
layer on some Tomatoes grilled eggplant
spinach and pitted kalamata olives - a
second slice of bread I had some hummus
and then I drizzle with some tahini
season it was that tar and sandwich the
whole thing together whole grain breads
are a great source of fiber which is
really important for promoting blood
sugar regulation satiety and regularity
finally my take on a school save PB&J
the Sun butter and Blackberry sandwich
start by spreading the Sun butter on a
slice of enriched white bread top with
fresh blackberries a sprinkle of
sunflower seeds and some hemp hearts
and then top with the second slice of
enriched white bread keep this close to
the classic I'm using an enriched white
bread crust totally optional according
to the University of Saskatchewan study
in rich spring foods like white bread
since we've 40% of the full 831 for some
of the iron and 23% of fiber in
Canadians diets making them a great
complement to the whole grains in your
family's diet so guys I hope you enjoyed
these recipes for my three favorite
sandwiches to help inspire your weekday
routine a big thank you again to healthy
greens Institute for collaborating with
me on this video to learn more about the
benefits of greens check out the healthy
green Institute's website in the
description below and if you love this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below some of your
favorite sandwich combinations I want to
know what breads and fillings you are
loving subscribe to the channel and I
will see you next time on Abbey's
kitchen bye
[Music]